et bien john le carré
merci d'être là ce soir avoue qu'il y
avait si souvent dans vos romans
racontent et des interrogatoires
pourquoi avaient fui y est vous plutôt
le souvent les questions des
journalistes vous savez je suis écrivain
pas profession je suis pas espions et je
préfère observer et j'ai une crainte
effroyable que si on entre on parle on
n'écrit pas assez je vous avais je vous
ai rencontré je vous ai proposé une
traduction simultanée où vous auriez le
choix de cette traduction et puis le
français
et puis vous m'avez dire non non pas du
tout je veux parler français pendant
toute l'émission
or ce tu dois dire c'est admirable et
les français vont apprécier bien entendu
mais enfin vous n'avez pas l'habitude
dans les cornouailles où vous habitez de
pratiquer notre langue
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors vous
savez j'étais professeur des langues
mais j'ai appris l'allemand est pas le
français et à salé je suis allé à
l'alliance française à londres pour
renouveler pour
pour fraîchir mes connaissances
françaises et ça ça m'a fait grand
plaisir c'était pour préparer cette
émission vous êtes allé à londres à
l'alliance française et vous avez reçu
des cours de français pendant combien de
temps combien de temps pendant j'ai fait
trente heures 30 30 30
avec jacqueline avec great est un des
gros lots ces caméras mais c'est là on
retrouve quand même quelque chose qui se
passe dans modeler c'est que vous êtes
un vrai professionnel et quand un agent
secret à une mission est bien là prépare
sérieusement et vous avez fait la même
chose
oui j'avais j'avais pensé que qu'il faut
il faut mieux faire un échec en français
que de réussir en anglais je vous
présente les les trois invités qui
dialogueront avec vous philippe labro
qui est romancier journaliste metteur en
scène de cinéma et qui est actuellement
directeur des programmes de rtl
et puis catherine david qui est
romancière et journaliste journaliste au
nouvel observateur et puis enfin edouard
baer qui est historien les journalistes
et notamment le grand reporter à
newsweek
alors je que je vous explique à tous les
trois et aux téléspectateurs comment
grâce à une cravate
j'ai enfin pu obtenir l'accord de john
le carré de venir ici alors c'était
tilly à capri il y a deux ans nous
étions tous les deux parce que nous
étions rencontrés compenser tous les
deux edwards pardon john le carré parce
que vous vous en aperceviez la
récompense d'un écrivain européen et moi
comme journalistes européens et je suis
arrivé le samedi soit très en retard le
dîner était commencé et je me suis dit
est ce que je veux une cravate ou prou
pas puis je me suis dit quand même et
les italiens sont très élégants j'ai
donc mis une cravate je suis arrivé
repas il y avait 200 personnes repas
offert par les éditeurs italiens et je
me suis aperçu qu'aucun homme ne portait
une cravate dans vite enlever la mienne
et je les mises dans ma poche
le lendemain à l'hôtel de ville de capri
on remet les prix
j'arrive je n'ai pas de cravate tous les
hommes avec une cravate
alors je me remets d'abord ma récompense
et puis je fais un petit laïus de
remerciement et jeudi deux shows je dis
d'abord je raconte l'histoire d'un
cravate puisque j'étais débraillé et
jeudi regardez john le carré lui c'est
un vrai anglais il connaît les usages il
connaît les le savoir vivre et il avait
une grave
il sait quand il faut mettre une cravate
et il sait quand il ne faut pas mettre
une cravate en que moi je ne le sais pas
en bon français et puis la deuxième
chose que j'ai dit c'est que j'avais un
peu scrupule à recevoir ce prix puisque
j'avais devant moi quelqu'un qui
monterait à lui tout seul les limites de
mon émission puisque ça faisait des
années des années qu'ils refusaient d'y
passer
et alors à ce moment là john le carré a
eu un geste magnifique il a fait ceci il
a fait ça il a retiré sa cravate
à ce moment là nous et nous avions tous
les deux le col ouvert et il me l'a
montré il m'a dit il suffira de me
montrer ceci et je viendrai à votre
émission
et cette cravate c'est la vôtre vous
m'avez offerte ya deux ans mais vous
pouvez écouter ça me ferait un très très
bon souvenir et donc ben voila je vais
faire une émission sans cravate qui va
me changer votre éditeur robert laffont
vienne publié la traduction john le
carré de votre dernier roman la maison
russie qui est un best-seller dans tous
les pays où il est déjà parus notamment
aux états unis où il a déclenché le pas
mal de controverses
il est vrai que c'est le premier roman
d'espionnage qui prend en compte la
glace note celle à prêter la pérestroïka
alors c'est un roman traduit de
l'anglais par mimi perrin et isabelle
perrin mais nous en parlerons de ce
roman dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission j'irai d'abord que les
français fassent connaissance avec john
le carré est d'abord une chose
évidemment assez étonnante c'est que
votre vrai nom c'est david john moores
cornwell
vous avez choisi comme ceux de nîmes un
nom qui sonne plutôt français le carré
pourquoi alors je vais vous dire la
vérité et puis je vais vous dire un
ensemble
la vérité c'est que j'étais ou temps où
j'ai fait mes débuts d'écrivain jeter
encore dans 9 à ronan fils et on m'a dit
c'était l'avis officiel
il faut choisir un nom de plume alors je
suis allé en main à mon éditeur anglais
il a dit alors choisi choisi c'est
quelque chose de très simple de très
anglo-saxon chunks mais blanc etc
et puis j'ai choisi john le carré
et la vérité c'est que je ne sais pas
d'où vient ce nom
mais la vérité est toujours tellement
ennuyante que pour les journalistes j'ai
inventé la fiction que j'étais sûr dans
un autobus de londres j'ai j'ai vu un
magasin de chaussures chaussures et il
s'appelait le magasin de john le carré
j'ai volé le nom mais c'est à mon sens
alors pourquoi pendant de nombreuses
années
vous avez refusé de dire que vous aviez
été un agent secret et maintenant vous
le volontiers vous le dites en vous
forçant un peu pourquoi avez vous refusé
longtemps de dire la vérité là dessus
j'ai pas refuser de te dire la vérité je
l'ait pas mentionné c'est tout mais
c'est la tradition de ces services fait
ou commencement gt gt très modeste à ce
sujet mais maintenant il ya des livres
des anciens membres de ses services qui
ont fait mention de moi et et c'est
devenu ridicule
alors je là vous vous l'avouer depuis
combien d'années voilà à l'égard d'aidé
d'état et je suis encore très modeste
le douar baer de la pluie alors depuis
trente ans je n'en sais plus rien
il faut le dire c'est charmant que les
journalistes disent je suis chef de
l'intelligence service et laissé mon
écriture c'est une acte imagination tout
un je ne m'occupe pas du tout de la
quitte
authenticité il s'agit de gérabilité
beaucoup de transformer les services
secrets en fait votre nom oui ça c'est
chambre je crois que je suis en partie
responsable du fait que john carney a
pour la première fois ouvertement avoué
qu'il a fait partie du monde secret il
se trouve qu'en 1983 moi je préparais
une couverture pour newsweek sur lui et
avant de le rencontrer pour sérieusement
où nous nous connaissions déjà mais mais
mais mais peu j'avais fais moi même une
une enquête assez poussée l'espion de
john mc j'ai été un peu l'espion et john
le carré d'une passé de john le carré
j'ai rencontré des gens dont beaucoup
sont morts maintenant qu'ils vont
raconter des choses très intéressantes
sur lui et j'ai gelé confrontée la
première la première fois que nous
sommes rencontrés je rappelle cette et
j'ai commandé une très bonne bouteille
de bourgogne
le sommelier du connaugh qui était censé
être celui du général de gaulle est très
très contents de cette commande nous
avons de ces bouteilles je lui ai dit
voilà je voudrais pas vous gêner mais je
voudrais vous dire ce que les gens
disent de vous et puis je lui et j'avais
dû note est juste sorti voilà intel qui
dit ceci l'autre qui dit cela et je
crois que à la suite de ça c'était une
façon bon je ne pouvais pas faire
autrement mais c'est une façon de
l'amener sur ce terrain là et par la
suite il m'en a dit beaucoup et moi j'ai
appris encore plus à quel âge at il été
recruté par les services secrets parce
que finalement vous êtes jeu
je ne veux pas affirmer de façon brésil
mais je crois que la version qui est
raconté dans un parfait de l'espion du
jeune homme et à berne qui est pris par
un homme qu'il admire mais qui est qui
et ce qui le qu'il attire sans l'attiré
et tous à d'ailleurs été admirablement
montré dans la version télévisuelle que
j'ai vu d'ailleurs avec vous dans votre
maison qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire je sais que en la
regardant j'ai compris que c'était vrai
alors c'est que ces 17es 818 en 17/18
ans et par là je crois par la suite je
me pensy alors il y à cette période
avant d'entrer au foreign office
ayant quitté il était professeur pour
pendant deux ans et le vague et là aussi
j'ai des bonnes raisons de croire que
pendant ces périodes il a été non pas
pour les services intérieurs la dgse
mais il a été peut-être contractuels
peut-être à plein temps pour
l'équivalent anglais de la dst et qui a
fait des choses assez extraordinaire
puisque il a fait des choses illégales d
effraction dans des bureaux il aurait
fait les choses qui n'étaient pas du
tout couvertes par ses chefs
et si par hasard il avait dit et piéger
ou s'il y avait eu une certaine
malchance ça aurait pu très mal tourner
pour lui philippe labro maintenant dans
l'espionnage tels que vrai donc
pratiquer puisque vous l'admettrez
aujourd'hui et dans vos romans
il ya toujours un moment donné ou même
si vos romans traite beaucoup la
psychologie et dans l'espionnage aussi
la psychologie compte
l'action intervient et donc la violence
dans vos livres
on liquide les agents
il y a des moments forts n'y a pas un
cadavre par page d'un livre jaune le
carême il ya toujours la mort qui
présente et donc ma question est très
indiscrète évidemment vous n'allez pas
me répondre mais j'aimerais quand même
savoir s'il en votre vie d'espion vous
avez jamais ou commis ou été impliqué
dans un acte de violence qui pouvait
même amener à un crime un homicide
je peux pas répondre vous savez pour moi
c'est une vie terminé
c'est une vive fini mais je sais que
quand je titille petit déjà je t'ai
espion la vie cui temps je suis venue
d'une famille très curieusement père
était négocions ambitieux trop ambitieux
il était souvent présent il a toujours
souvent fait faillite et ils étaient
aussi très aimable et très ambitieux
pour nous et il nous fallait
mon frère et moi il nous fallait
dissimulé dire que nous étions riches
que nous étions pauvres observé pour
survivre dire que nous étions de la
grande bourgeoisie
quand nous étions des parvenus c'était
une mentalité que j'ai hérité de ma
jeunesse que j'ai appliqué pour peu de
temps dans une carrière qui est devenue
maman credit balance mme mama bilan à la
banque comme ma jeunesse mais mais c'est
une vie qui me servent de caen théâtre
comme comédie humaine rétrospective est
ce que je pense la question est ce que
vous êtes arrivé dans votre vie d'agent
secret de lutter avec ou contre des
espions français n'ont jamais jamais
portiez-vous un revolver
non non jamais non non mais pas
aujourd'hui les six noms dans ses pas
d'importance est inverse et vous avez
dit ceci dans un pur espions vous et je
vous c'est un personnage est dit nous ne
sommes nous les espions que des escrocs
lego va nous mettons notre nature de
malfaiteurs au service de l'état et vous
vous feriez votre cette phrase
aujourd'hui sur les rives ça réfléchit
parfaitement ce que j'ai dit à philippe
j'avais une jeunesse qui pouvait aller
comme ci ou comme ça j'aurais pu devenir
petit criminel peut-être mais une
combinations de de l'éducation anglaise
dans les pensions là la vocation
colonist que nous héritons ça m'a dirigé
vers la service public
mais c'est vrai que par exemple philby
le célèbre espion dont qui a été recruté
un britannique étaient recrutés par les
soviétiques a eu un peu une jeunesse
comme la vôtre c'est à dire un père
distant et lui donc a choisi une autre
voie
est ce que est ce que dans la mesure
vous avez eu à peu près la même enfance
est-ce que vous ne pourriez pas être
aujourd'hui indulgent son égard non ça
je suis très reconnaissant pour cette
question parce que philby et 10 pour moi
une sorte méphistophélès pendant une
grande partie de ma vie parce que j'ai
souvent pensé que grâce à dieu j'ai pris
une autre direction peut-être je suis
devenu traître littéraire
mais vous savez philippe latry c'était
un journaliste cette journaliste anglais
il a visité chez philby avant sa mort et
il a demandé à fabriquer ce qu'ils
pensent de moi et fait lui a répondu il
ne m'aime pas et j'ai le sentiment qu'il
sait quelque chose à l'égard de moi je
sais pas ce que c'est est ce que ce que
j'ai su c'était l'effet d'une telle
paire sur la jeunesse sur les
expectations les attentes qui plus tard
dans la vie qui sont le résultat de
vivre dans l'ombre d'un tel homme d'un
tyran nature d'un tyran et est un escroc
qui était aussi le père de films
vous avez dit aussi dans ce même livre
que le monde secret attire
particulièrement les gens dont je crois
je sais pas si j'arrive à le traduire
enfin dont les âmes à son lâche lousse
link
oui oui que parce que justement ils ont
ils ont ce sentiment de ne pas
appartenir à une société a une famille
et c'est que le monde secret devient
leur famille
ensuite je crois que vous avez vous êtes
retourné contre cette famille parce que
dans tous vos livres
cette famille là vous n'êtes pas tendre
avec elle
non non non je sais pas alors c'est
surtout un pur espion c'est dans un pur
espions que john le carré a raconté à
régler ses comptes avec son père et avec
sa famille qui est un moment d'une
certaine manière autobiographique mais
catherine david une question
et moi je pense que quand on est élevé
dans le secret
on a un rapport très ambivalents et très
compliqué avec le secret c'est à dire
qu'en même temps on le déteste parce que
c'est ça qui rend la vie impossible et
le mensonge et tout ce que ça toutes ces
choses qui vont avec
et puis en même temps il ya une
fascination il ya une sorte de plaisir
comme ça la clandestinité vous avez
fouiller dans les tiroirs de votre père
vous avez fait des choses qui vous a
obligé à faire en soirée et je pense que
dans votre oeuvre
le secret joue un rôle absolument
fondamental est que en réalité vous êtes
un des rares écrivains qui se cache plus
derrière leurs oeuvres qui ne se montre
c'est à dire en général quand on écrit
quand on croit que les écrivains en tout
cas écrivent pour pour se dire quelque
chose d'eux mêmes et vous je pense que
vous écrivez pour cacher quelque chose
de vous même ce qui d'une certaine
manière revient au même
vous posez d'accord sur 7 oui oui oui je
suis d'accord
et vous savez les institutions que nous
nous nous choisissons sont normalement
les substituts parente des parents des
deux mères et pères et on a sion n'est
pas très bien ancrée on a la même
relation entre amour et haine wifi
bluetooth et normes différence et se
passer quand on parlait de file vivons
fils b et donc l'homme qui a trahi
humaine en bretagne les services secrets
et vous avez été vous même un espion au
service de la grande bretagne et vous
n'avez pas trahi en d'autres termes d un
patriote
car on n'est pas allé simplement dans
les services secrets à cause de votre
passé familial nous être aussi était ce
poème pardon d'utiliser un mot aussi on
peut servir votre patrie oui mais j'ai
compris la tentation de faire encore un
saut et de trail de trahir ce commun
embrassés mais quand on est un jeune
homme et qu'on appartient aux services
secrets
ça doit être très fascinant d'être au
dessus des lois et au dessus de la
morale
oui oui
et de se sentir spécial et il ya aussi
des déchets en face des gens fascinante
qui entrent dans les portes de ce monde
il y a des gens pliante aussi mais ce
qui est normal c'est la médiocrité
c'est un monde de fantômes en réalité
rock around the phantom pas que ma
légende pas les agents mais les
bureaucrates les gens qui sont dans le
cirque qui sont dans la maison qui oui
et disent qu'ils sont membres se sont
défendus de ce sont des espaces qu'ils
sont à huis clos sans gruissan et le son
des hommes en gris comme vous dites oui
oui les hommes en gris que le grand là
ce qui est important actuellement c'est
de tuer l'homme en gris qui somnole en
chacun de nous
j'avais toujours l'impression que ces
gens là justement sont toujours en
représentation et qui ne sont vrai que
quand ils sont entre eux quand ils sont
en train ils sont tout à fait différents
oui est beaucoup plus dure d'ailleurs et
cynique est ce que c'est ce que vous
d'ailleurs vous vous arrêterez à travers
vos livres même les premiers je crois
que c'est vous aviez à la fois une
fascination pour ce monde et une
certaine répulsion
oui oui c'est vrai très bien alors on va
passer au roman au livre de john carey
et catherine bercy oui une dernière
question
je voulais vous dire il me semble que
dans à travers toute l'oeuvre
j'ai un trou que le thème principal de
votre oeuvre
finalement c'est le combat des agents
appartenant à une démocratie occidentale
contre les agents d'un pays totalitaire
or le grand problème qui se pose à eux
constamment c'est de savoir quelle
méthode il a utilisé ce qu'ils vont
utiliser les méthodes de leurs
adversaires où est-ce qu'ils vont garder
les mains propres et être moins efficace
or ce qui se passe finalement c'est
qu'ils ont ils ne cessent de dire qu'ils
se reconnaissent dans leurs adversaires
qu'ils sont pareils parce qu'ils font
les mêmes choses même les emploient les
mêmes méthodes
finalement ils font la même chose de
dire justifie et la fin par les moyens
les moyens par la fin qu'il est je pense
que ce thème
finalement vous donner une réponse très
très pessimiste à cette question morale
oui c'est la question impossible c'est
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans la
défense de la démocratie que la
démocratie reste une institution qu'il
vous défendre voilà oui c'est que c'est
presque impossible
on a l'impression que mr que vous avez
quand même pris très au sérieux ce cette
expression française
c'est un c'est un sale métier mais je le
fais seulement
oui parce que les finalement entre carla
le personnage soviétique qui a été la
trame de d'au moins trois de vos livres
et les autres smiley le reste il n'y a
pas une telle ou telle grande tellement
une grande différence
est ce que vous voyez une différence
entre un côté un autre dans leur
technique dans leur façon d'agir dans
l'ordre dans le terrorisme dans leur
absence de morale nous qu il peut y en
avoir une
et à la fin de la carie de la carrière
de ce mal est comme gelée décrites c'est
vrai qu'il qu'il a ils se détestent mali
parce qu'il a gagné avec des méthodes
qui qui qui qu'il déteste mais il faut
dire que dans la lutte entre smileys et
carla la morale était en tout cas dans
le camp de l'ouest
nous tous savons maintenant que c'était
un empire effroyable qui est maintenant
qu'ils sont radieux qui se désagrège
alors les actions de ce mal et
justifiée mais éthiquement et moralement
dégoûtante
catherine david dites-nous en quelques
phrases pourquoi les romans d'espionnage
de john le carré dépasse de beaucoup le
genre et relève de la literary ça bien
entendu c'est un peu quoi c'est une
question très importante parce que c'est
enfin il faut rappeler qu'à l'époque où
l'espion et
l'espion qui venait du froid est sorti
il y avait je sais pas sur le marché
peut-être 250 roman d'espionnage cette
année là et puis qu'à un roman qui est
sorti et que tout le monde a lu et dans
tout le monde se souvient et qui a été
écrit après la vision qui a fait jaune
qu'a eu john le carré de la construction
du mur de berlin
alors c'est d'autant plus émouvant
évidemment le voir aujourd'hui que le
mur n'existe plus puisque il a commencé
son oeuvre en quelque sorte au pied du
mur passera derrière l'estrade weeds
nazaire après pardon c'est qu'il y avait
eu deux autres livres qui était sorti
avant que les gens n'ont pas tous lui
moins connu que je trouve très
remarquable qui se passe d'ailleurs à
londres et dans la banlieue londonienne
et qui déjà a donné les qualités qu'ils
font comme vous dites
s'est interrogé bernard que c'était
évidemment absolument pas des romans
d'espionnage ce sont des romans taux
courts c'est la très bonne littérature
c'est à dire une reddition de
l'atmosphère
une description des caractères des
visages un sens inné du dialogue est
évidemment la construction du récit
c'est à dire le scénario qui vous prend
et qui vous emmène jusqu'à la fin du
livre
oui moi ce que je veux dire c'est que il
me semble c'est que vous avez choisi le
roman d'espionnage pas seulement parce
que vous connaissiez mais aussi parce
que vous êtes aperçu que le roman
d'espionnage est une bonne fenêtre
oui sur l'histoire et en même temps un
bon microscope sur les as oui oui c'est
ça activement permet finalement de
raconter tout ce que vous voulez à
travers luis saez il ya aussi j'ai john
le carré
c'est l'extraordinaire faculté de
prendre à l'événement et de l'insérer
dans une oeuvre qui est une oeuvre
littéraire
par exemple si vous prenez le livre au
neubourg secours le coma qu'un collégien
comme un collégien
bon il a trait entre autres à hong kong
à la guerre du vietnam à la fin de la
guerre du vietnam au cambodge et c'est
page là se lisent sont du tout qu'il
soit nécessaire de d'être un aficionado
des romans d'espionnage
c'est une description je dirais surtout
ces chapitres sur la fin du cambodge
s'est elle mérite une anthologie sociale
dans tout ce qui est écrit sur cette
bernard
est-ce que ça relève du grand
journalisme dignité du journaliste voilà
la crise et loué comme on espionne c'est
avec une 16 d'observer les détails
alors est ce que est ce qu'on peut dire
que le roman le roman tel cool pratiqué
c'est la continuation de l'espionnage
mais sous une forme divertissante et
agréable et surtout moins dangereuse
pour vous oui beaucoup moins touché 2 et
r oui ce sont des fables déguisés et
c'est toujours amusant quand je quand je
lis les quand parise comparaison avec
l'authenticité et ça ça ne me touche pas
du tout parce que je veux être crédible
je vais vous je veux compter et si
l'électeur devient partie de mon nom de
valence s'est achevée et décoré
l'histoire avec les détails c'est pour
convaincre faut lui prendre la main et
le conduire avec moi il est actuellement
c'est tellement ça que nous avons
abandonné penser à une une série de
télévision pour comme un collégien vous
appelez et dans l'histoire on s'est
aperçu que tous ces chapitres sur la
guerre du vietnam et du cambodge
n'avancez pas du tout l'histoire d'un
abattement et pourtant on s'en était pas
rendu compte avant parce qu'on est
tellement pris par ça
quant aux justes manque ont été amenés
au cambodge au vietnam et ailleurs sans
du tout se rendre compte que c'est un
luxe que les anglais appellent un art en
rouge c'est un c'est une distraction
pour empêcher le lecteur de trouver la
filière le est ce que au fond le rôle du
romancier n'est pas un peu semblable à
celui du rôle de l'espion c'est-à-dire
de construire des fables des mensonges
mais cohérente
oui mais vous savez les espions france a
aussi oui mais je dis oui
l'espionné ou écrire un roman est ce que
ce n'est pas la même chose certaine
manière
et pour moi c'est la même chose je
lançais observé faire des fictions se
rendre attrayant en tout cas comté
persuadée volet dissimulé et surtout
clerc o m ce sont les lecteurs
mais là trop c'est que c'est la
diversité des lecteurs quand on parle de
john le carré il ya toujours quelqu'un
ce sont des gens très différents des
lecteurs allez-y non je pense que john
le carré n'est pas vraiment un romancier
ni la guerre froide ni ni de
l'espionnage si vous prenez ces ses
romans les ce que ce soit l'esma les que
ce soit un espoir parfait c'est du
dickens il ya une cinquantaine de
personnages des jeux mais il ya beaucoup
de personnages d'ailleurs dans le
dernier il y en a il y en a vraiment
plusieurs dizaines mais smiley c'est
vrai c'est votre héros c'est vous qui
avez rendu célèbre ce nom est ce que
vous pourriez nous le décrire smiley tel
qu'il apparaît au moins dans 20 dans
beaucoup de romans mais surtout dans les
trois romans qui sont d'ailleurs réédité
dans la collection bouquins
quand j'ai commencé d'écrire au sujet
des smileys c'était presque mon père et
maintenant il est devenu un peu usé un
peu pessimiste il s'arrange
c'était c'est vraiment un produit de la
guerre froide
et si on veut si on a la nostalgie pour
la guerre froide
on va à ce mal et mais à ce moment c'est
une ère de l'optimisme de la créativité
de la passion même l'avenir et fascinant
et ce n'est pas le monde passe mal et
alors je les abandonner il y a
dix ans déjà parce que j'étais certain
que que la guerre froide sera bientôt
fini et il était pour moi fini aussi
mais c'est bon pour les gens qui étaient
les français qui nous aurait encore pas
lui il faut dire que smiley c'est un peu
le contraire de james bond
c'est vraiment le contraire est dedans
parce que il est la preuve qu'il est
interprétée à l'écran admirablement dans
la série télévisée qui est d'ailleurs
passé sur l'antenne de quoi bien par le
guinness un extraordinaire comme bien
bien sûr et qui est le contraire de il
faut dire aussi que john connolly est le
héros la maison russie jeune et j'ai vu
le tournage c'est assez extraordinaire
on dit d'ailleurs beaucoup de choses
intéressantes
qu'at il dit par exemple oui il freine
admirable acteurs et puis il dit il est
tellement plus spirituelle qui aiment
flâner mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
les romans d'espionnage tel que tels
qu'on peut les lire les vôtres nous
montre des gens quand même on n'a pas
tellement envie de devenir un agent
secret parce que ce sont des gens quand
même qu'ils sont désespérés qu'ils ne
savent pas où est la vérité qui ne
savent pas où est le mensonge et qui
finalement aboutissent à un cul de sac
et souvent payent de leur vie
le mensonge oui si c'est pas les leurs
c'est sont ceux d'en face c'est pas
évident donc j'essaie vraiment nous
sommes souvent dans le canton dans le
dans le monde de john le carré ou
d'ailleurs
je crois que finalement dont nous allons
parler de ce livre au 6 mai mais ma
thèse à moi si j'ai une thèse c'est que
se livrent aussi mais en fait pour les
livres précédents le lez hérault de du
des livres de john le carré sont des
gens isolés qui sont les victimes à la
fois de leurs propres services et du
service des autres ils sont toujours
pris dans un étau et ça c'est une idée
force qui existe est le premier à
prendre
à propos de smiley je passe quand vous
marquants je vous ai rencontrés au
moment de la publication d'un pur espion
vous m'avez dit que vous aviez
et abandonner smileys et que c'est ça
qui vous avez permis d'écrire un pur
espion qui en fait était un livre sur
votre père est d'ailleurs à cette époque
là vous avez fait des déclarations vous
avez raconté l'histoire de votre père
que personne ne connaissait qui lui le
grand secret et smiley adua a eu besoin
de disparaître ps que pourquoi avez-vous
toujours été fasciné par l'allemagne
parce que quand j'étais petit alors
j'avais 5 ans 15 ans je ne suis j'ai eut
refusé de rentrer à la pension anglaise
où j'étais élève et j'ai dit à mon père
je veux devenir je sais pas européen
continental j'ai pris refuge comme comme
réfugié politique dans la suisse et
voulait quitter l'angleterre pour
alléger quitter oui pour aller ensuite
je suis allé à l'université de berne
j'avais alors oui saison 16 ans et à ce
temps là nous avions des des professeurs
fantastique émigré juif dont la plupart
et l'âme allemande si vous voulez la
culture allemande et il a pour moi à
berne
et je me suis plongé dans ce monde pour
pour pour pour me trouver une autre âme
une autre identité qui n'était ni de mon
père ni de la grande bretagne et même
quand je suis rentré à l'angleterre
j'ai affecter un accent allemand ce
petit idiot mais mais j'étais réfugié
dans mon imagination
maintenant ça sera un accent français
edouard baer m'a dit que vous êtes
capables d'ailleurs en langue allemande
où la pratique est si bien le pouvaient
prendre différents accents allemand
et si salma est tout à fait
extraordinaire et sa pelouse a su est
alors donc vous êtes est ce que c'est
vrai ce que le choix vous l'avez dit
catherine david sait que vous étiez à
berlin vous étiez en allemagne quand le
mur de berlin était construit oui oui
j'étais là j'étais dans l'ambassade
britannique à bonn et je suis allé à
berlin et j'étais la faim dans la
construction du mur c'est dire le monde
était coupée en deux à partir de ce
moment là et dans tous vos livres et le
monde est coupée en deux mais ce que c
est ce que c'est le mur de berlin qui
vous inspirent et l'espion qui venait du
froid
je cherchais à ce temps-là nouveau roman
c'était exactement à ce moment où je
suis arrivé à berlin
je cherchais la paradoxe pur parce que
j'étais tellement fatiguée par seconde
ce monde secret déjà et j'ai vu ça
hérisse et 700 bull et c'était pour moi
un éclat de lumière et je suis rentré à
abonnent et j'ai commencé à écrire
chaque matin de 5h à 8h j'ai écrit même
camp que j'étais à l'ambassade à midi
j'ai pas fait les grands déjeuners j'ai
écrit j'ai écrit cinq semaines c'est
fini c'est roulant et puis j'ai fait des
laits coupage des coupures et
et c'est fini mais j'avais c'était d'un
livre que j'ai écrit avec le rajout
corps l'a rejeté c'était dégoûtant
j'avais comme tous les rêveurs j'étais
aussi cynique et et ggg combiné si vous
voulez l'idéalisme avec ce rage et ce
cynisme alors l'espion qui venait du
froid vous rend célèbre dans le monde
entier et monsieur martin pitt entendu
retreats et sa part le martin grandir un
long métrage avec richard burton dans le
rôle principal
et alors c'est aujourd'hui au moment où
le mur de berlin devient une ruine
il est intéressant de revoir la scène
finale de l'espion qui venait du froid
c'est la scène du franchissement du mur
par les deux fuyards qui sont joués par
richard burton et claire bloom
je rappelle que le film date de 1965
l'espion qui venait du froid
arrêté
ah c'est par cette petite et en os vous
verrez les mais d'abord il ya une rangée
des barbelés un gouffre à abu dhabi
pierrât l'endroit où vous pouvez passer
les détachements a placé dans le mur
d'écrans pont de fer jusqu'à une
certaine hauteur après vous de vous
débrouiller montés les premiers quand
vous serez en retirer la fille comment
passera-t-elle les barbelés
on les a coupés s'il arrive quelque
chose si vous tombez aussi vous pouvez
laisser ne revenez pas en arrière au
voisinage du mur on tire à vue
il faut que vous passiez votre ami vous
atteindra dé l'autre côté et ça pique
[Applaudissements]
voilà bah je peux vous montrer la la fin
parce que c'est terrible elle est
terrible est ce que john le carré scoop
ainsi qu'un jour vous verriez la
destruction du mur de berlin
bah oui oui oui certainement mais pas la
destruction de l'espionnage ah non non
pas de les penser vous pensez qu'un jour
vous verriez ici ah oui en certainement
dans quelques mois tout en quelques
temps mais oui ça viendra oui non mais
vraiment non mais pas maintenant mais
parce que le mur au fond il est détruit
d'une certaine manière même s'il est
encore là mais je veux dire toutes ces
années dernière vous vous disiez un jour
le pardon oui c'est ça je vous disais
est ce que vous pensiez que le mur à
jour serait dès lors et non à pas dans
ma vie non je n'ai pas cru non c'est
extraordinaire c'est un moment
d'histoire absolument extraordinaire
nous sommes très privilégiés de vivre à
ce moment j'ai trouvé cette très sûr
parce que c'est pas logique de voir ce
mur dans le film de martin ritt ce coup
de voir ce mur qui était
mais aussi devant le mur que carla elle
fait prisonnier oui oui j'ai c'était à
ce moment que je me suis dit s'il est
bien finir la guerre froide
je voulais vous demander vous avez dû en
tant que fonctionnaire signé un une
reconnaissance que jamais où ne
divulguera y ait des choses secrètes sur
ce que vous aviez vu expérience
expérimentés
si vous n'aviez pas eu cette contrainte
est ce que vous livre aurait été
différent non non parce que je il faut
vraiment pas exagérer je n'ai pas fait
beaucoup
je n'ai pas vu beaucoup de ces deux de
ces choses c'est l'imagination qui règle
et j'aurais peut-être essayer de
démontrer l'absurdité
mais c'est très difficile l'absurdité
énorme de beaucoup de choses qui sont
faits en secret et je les ai essayé une
fois c'était le livre n'était pas très
très bon et s'appelait la guerre en
miroir où j'ai touché sur la comédie de
ces choses parce que le problème c'est
si on écrit honnêtement pour la plupart
se sont pas des conspirations ce sens
dès des erreurs effroyable est ce que
vous croyez que justement pour reprendre
ce livre
cette thèse du livre ou délibérément
quelqu'un ait sacrifié pour encourager
justement la montée ou une rivalité
hesdin une bureaucratie au sein d'un
service est ce que c'est possible ce
genre de chose que chez les anglais
pendant la paix non non je crois pas
vraiment sacrifié les gens pauvres pour
gagner des points dans une lutte
bureaucratique non non non vous en
parlait comme d'un jeu c'est un jeu
d'enfant ce sont des enfants qui jouent
en même temps les we qui donnent leur
jeu ont des conséquences mortelles en
dehors de l'aspiration de votre propre
vie et vos fantasmes d'enfants
certainement est ce que vous avez eu une
influence littéraire majeur qui vous a
poussé vers cette écriture
oui je crois oui une expérience oui
peut-être où je j'ai senti où je me suis
vraiment détesté j'ai fait quelque chose
qui était d'espis câble de ce périmètre
visant méprisable oui mais mais je vous
en parle en jeu vous vous demandez quel
extraordinaire c'est que tout à l'heure
on vous a posé la question pour avoir
des réponses ce genre là nous n'avons
pas obtenu tout d'un coup philippe labro
vous pose une question sur vos
influences littéraires et nous obtenons
la réponse enfin mauvais
on peut demander quelles étaient ses
d'aqmi mais non ils veulent simplement
vivre à bron disait simplement très
simplement vos influences littéraires
quels sont les écrivains qui vous ont
influencé les enfants c'est très bien
parce que oui les comptes de sa masse
est même peut-être à shenzhen conrad
joseph joseph kony et jeff green
naturellement l'américain silencieux
quoique à bien troquer oui oui le g 20
qui se passe justement en indochine et
relic oui mais mais surtout les romans
du xixème siècle et balzac surtout elle
me donne donc la comédie humaine
oui ma comédie humaine le jeu des cats
et sa façon d'écrire les ja et jouets
qu'on en vienne maintenant la maison
russie philippe labro quelques phrases
présentez-nous si c'est possible ce
roman assez étonnant et étonnant parce
que évidemment voir les prophétique il a
été écrit alors que l'appareil stromae
glace noces lrgp orbach chef et a
commencé
mais ce qui est prophétique c'est
qu'effectivement je crois vous l'avez
écrit à deux ans maintenant
au fond il raconte ce qui se passe d'une
part mais surtout il est formidablement
bien construit et il faut quand même
dire en gros ce qui se passe c'est à
moscou lors d'une foire de livres des
carnets qui sont transmis par une très
belle femme qui appelle katia une russe
afin d'être envoyé à un éditeur
publisher en vain un homme qui s'occupe
de livres en angleterre qui s'appelle
barlet blair
et ces carnets contiennent des textes un
peu fou mais surtout par moment des
révélations très précises qui disent en
gros le chevalier soviétique est en
train de perdre son armure nord dans son
armure et en gros l'occident ne se rend
pas compte à quel point nous soviétique
sommes faibles et tout notre arsenal est
totalement pourri gangréné et nous ne
sommes pas compétents et la course aux
armements et donc à placer un mensonge
extraordinaire qu'il faut arrêter il
faut donc faire publier ses carnets qui
sont écrits par un personnage mystérieux
dont on apprendra qu'il est surnommé
goethe
il est né avec deux âmes comme faust et
le manuscrit passe donc à l'ouest grâce
à cette jeune femme qui évidemment est
en danger en faisant passer ce muscle et
lite on entend les mains les services
secrets britanniques qui convoque et qui
renaît qui découvrent l'éditeur à qui il
était destiné et qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'ils ont commandés en anglais
une patate chaude entre les mains
c'était extraordinaire mais qui n'arrive
pas à croire que ça ne soit pas fortuit
qui est pas autre chose derrière qu'il
n'y ait pas les fameuses combinaisons
est-ce qu'il n'a pas été écrit exprès
par le kgb pour leur et l'occident donc
on commence déjà les longs convois la
vitesse constitue en spirale et cet
éditeur est renvoyée en union soviétique
pour entrer en contact avec l'homme qui
a écrit ce livre et qu'il avait
d'ailleurs rencontré quelques années
auparavant et pour essayer d'établir un
allié avec lui et pour enfin apporter
aux américains qui rentre dans la sphère
car évidemment la course aux armements
c'est essentiellement les états unis une
réponse
donc voilà trois personnages clés parler
blair se perdre un seul merveilleux
personnage britannique joueur de saxo
alcoolique qui aime les femmes mais qui
est solitaire qui est malheureux et qui
en fait est à la recherche d'un amour
cette femme katia superbe car c'est un
personnage de femme très important et je
crois que c'est une des caractéristiques
de ce livre équipe peut-être une des
raisons de son succès en dehors de sa
merveilleuse écriture c'est qu'il y a
je crois véritablement le premier grand
personnage féminin dans l'oeuvre de john
le carré et goethe
oui oui m'enfin celui ci me semble enfin
bref il ya but
ce savant à la fois lyrique et délirant
et en même temps très lucide tu dis la
vérité
qui dit tout ça sert à rien essayons
d'être un petit peu
arrêtons de faire la recherche
scientifique et faisons la recherche sur
la nature humaine il faut être à la
destruction
alors donc le nôtre edit retourne à
moscou et ce qui va se passer là bien
entendu on va rentrer parce qu'il se
passe parce qu'on croit qu'il va se
passer bien évidemment comme c'est
remarquablement agence est construit de
façon telle que vous ne pouvez pas
lâcher le livre est il y a entre autres
choses une très très belle histoire
d'amour
non ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est un
roman d'espionnage un roman d'amour et
c'est un roman politique
prenons d'abord le roman d'espionnage
c'est vrai que comme dans tout bon dans
tous vos romans
il ya des masques des trahisons des
pièges des mensonges et on sait jamais
si celui qui parle dit vrai et on ne
sait pas si celui qui parle mais pas en
train de vous tendre un piège mortel
c'est toujours ça l'esprit et ce
document dont parlait philippe labro
c'est qu'on ne sait pas si au fond ça
mais c'est un faux ou six bouts s'il dit
vrai et comment le savoir quand on
habite de l'autre côté c'est mais une
histoire comme ça qu'est fabuleuse et
comment vous l'avez sorti de votre
imagination où il ya quelque chose de
vrai que vous avez pris quelque part il
y avait une histoire de vrai
c'était l'histoire de penkovski savant
militaire chez
j'ai le kremlin qui a essayé je crois
pendant deux ans de trahir son pays il
est allé jusqu'au bout à une rainure
réunion de cocktails il s'est approché
des les attacher des ambassades il a dit
j'ai laissé crever des secrets pour vous
et tout le monde d'accord et rés à la
fin il a trouvé un pauvre anglais qui
s'appelait green qui n'était pas du tout
espions mais il l'a cru et il lui a
donné des secrets des secrets
extraordinaires qui ont aidé à kenzy ou
pendant la crise de cuba qu'il en est
des vraiment de savoir que les russes ne
pouvait pas gagner une guerre nucléaire
oui donc vous êtes partie de quelque
chose de vrai et à partir de là votre
imagination et j'ai rencontré par hasard
un ancien membre d'un de l'intelligence
service qui m'a dit que ne savais pas
jusqu'à maintenant si c'était de
désinformation délibérée et caetera et
le fait qu'il n'existe pas la vérité
c'est qu'on ne le sait pas encore
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas un peut-être
ans et maintenant mais il ya cinq ans et
qu'on ait transparence le secret prendre
de plus en plus d'importance parce que
ça devient en plus compliqué a dit il
n'ya pas une vérité les autres
caractéristiques de
la maison russie c'est que ça se passe
un très grand parti en russie à moscou
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
john le carré taille pour la première
fois sa vie il ya très peu de temps mais
les italiques en semaine mais attendez
penghu publier vos autrement vous étiez
traîné dans la boue en urss où était
considéré comme un suppôt du capitalisme
comme un adversaire résolu
pourquoi vous ont-ils invités il y a
deux ans alors j'ai stimuler
l'invitation festivités et maintenant
ils ont dit on vous êtes fous jamais
alors l'attaché culturel à l'ambassade
soviétique à londres m'a dit après que
je suis allé en si vous pouvez allez
tout le monde parle et c'est ridicule
mais
soudainement ils ont ils ont dit oui et
je suis allé à sheremetyevo à les
reports de moscou et est le chef de
l'union soviétique des écrivains étaient
là il m'a embrassé trois fois et et
j'étais là si j'arrivais ce qui est
remarquable c'est qu'on voit que ça vous
a quand même formidable ont séduit
peut-être parce que justement vous y
pensiez puis si longtemps vous en parle
depuis si longtemps on a l'impression
qu'il ya un coup de foudre de votre part
rejoindre le carré pour moscou et pour
les gens les êtres humains qui les
russes et wim hommes et femmes oui
c'était facile
c'était très excitant et personne ne
savait à ce temps là si la pérestroïka
était et est vrai étaient de la
désinformation c'est une grande
conspiration et il y avait des
journalistes américains et des zones
d'état qui ont dit non c'est cécité
énorme mensonge et je voulais savoir
d'abord 6,7 est vrai toujours la même
chose
prométhée toujours sincère est-ce que
vous pensez que gorbatchev et sincère au
mi6 absolument puisque vous peut-être
vous avez par exemple vous êtes allé
dans une dans un de ces appartements que
vous décrivez où les gens vivent à
woodbridge ya plusieurs vous avez pris
des notes constamment ou
il entend comment ça se passe quand on
est en train d suis rentré à l'hôtel et
puis j'ai écrit des notes
oui mais enfin vous saviez que l'hôtel
est quand même surveiller qui avait des
micros dans votre chambre est lui dedans
mais oui j'ai admis j'assume que ça
arrive toujours pas scellé dans le
village de où est enterré et enterré
pasternak que vous décrivez dans le
roman donc une ville à gérer des kiwis
description très très intéressante c'est
alors tout de même les américains ils
vont un peu fort quand ils disent que
votre voyage d'une certaine manière en
urss vous a retourné et que vous alors
là c'est quand même un peu fort même si
vous avez été séduit par les russes
vous faites quand même une critique très
acerbe et b traîne parfois violentes de
la vie en urss
vous savez un roman quand un personnage
il s'agit de les possibilités de la
caractère de l'histoire ce que j'ai vu
tout de suite en russie c'était le fait
que tout était changé c'était la fin de
la peur chez les gens déjà et je sentis
un monde en mouvement et j'étais très
séduit par les possibilités de l'avenir
part par le fait que dans ma vie ça va
tout changer
alors la future l'avenir est très
dangereux
sans doute mais il ya des possibilités
créatives pour nous tous et c'était
facile ans et j'étais passionné par sa
mémé je suis pas naïve ce qui est naïve
c'est de penser que les les
les slogans les du passé nous serviront
dans l'avenir c'est fini oui ça c'est
réaliste non pour être réaliste qu'il
faut est aussi être idéaliste à ce
moment ce qui est ce qui est étonnant
john car il sait que donc philippe labro
le rappelait vous avez écrit ce roman il
ya deux ans et dont il ya deux ans ils
se passaient pas évidemment les choses
que nous savons aujourd'hui et vous avez
donc cru en la glace note pérestroïka et
dans ce roman où déjà vous analysez les
changements dans la vie des espions
notamment dans des les relations que
pourraient apporter cette glace noces et
cette paire est strict à c'est ça qui
est étonnant au fond j'ai envie de dire
mais vous nombreux vous reprenez si je
me trompe
vous dites à ce moment il ya deux ans la
guerre froide devient beaucoup moins
froides dont
donc les agents secrets ne vont plus se
comporter comme au temps de la guerre
froide
oui est ce que c'est vrai non ce que
j'ai si j'ai compris votre question
correctement j'ai une grande peur que
notre bureaucratie que notre mentalité
ne se changera assez vite pour que nous
nous adressons aux changements
inévitables que nous avons nous mêmes
une nostalgie pour la guerre froide que
j'ai que j'ai remarqué chez mes lecteurs
et chez les critiques que vous savez que
vous lisez oui le mur
il a brillé vraiment que l'ap que la
glace noske est là pour toujours
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que même
maintenant deux ans après l'écriture de
votre livre que la possibilité par
exemple d'un d'un véritable coup d'état
militaire soviétique et à écarter
complètement et que les conséquences de
cela ne pourrait être immense
je crois que c'est bien possible
ça pourrait être terrible mais ça ne
sera pas la même chose encore
nous nous nous devons être tolérant
parce que les russes ne comprennent pas
du tout la démocratie il fend les
expériences maintenant mais ils n'ont
ils n'ont pas comme les français comme
les anglais une jeunesse déjà pour la
démocratie comme monsieur mitterrand a
dit ils n'ont pas l'habitude de la
liberté quotidienne et à cause de ça il
y aura peut-être des révolutions des
grandes révolutions des luttes entre les
minorités des luttes contre les slavik
etc
mais tout ça c'est bien possible mais ça
va changer ça va changer ça ne sera ça
ne restera pas la même chose
il nous faut de l'imagination et ça
change quelque chose aussi dans nos pays
je pense que c'est ça change quelque
chose de façon presque aussi importante
chez nous et c'est ça que vous montrez
nous ce que vous décrivez qui est
passionnant c'est la confrontation entre
les américains les bureaux catania est
donc ce document qui est apporté lui
mais on se rend bien compte que vous
venez de dire que les américains que
vous décrivez d'ailleurs de façon très
ironique et rituels je sais pas comment
ils vous ont reçu là bas mais mal la cia
y est l'acier pas bien vu la diplomate
s'était dos à dos étaient les amants
grimsel
alors oui je voudrais oui ça c'est ce
que 10 buts higuain qui le physicien
soviétique et qu'il dit il dit à
l'éditeur 1 joue un jour à lire ça ça
c'est très fort les experts les hommes
en gris sont des fanatiques
ils ne résolvent rien ils sont à la
solde du système qui les emploient ils
le perpétuent
quand nous nous ferons torturé ce sera
par des experts quand nous serons pendu
ce sera par des experts
quand le monde sera détruit ce ne sera
pas par des fous mais par de sages
experts et par l'ignorance
incommensurable des bureaucrates ça
c'est sale et c'est vrai aussi bien d'un
côté comme de l'autre à ouides que de
l'eau parce qu'en fait les américains ne
veulent pas croire à ces documents non
c'est très histoire aussi parce qu'ils
veulent que la course aux armements
continue parce que ça enrichit le
complexe militaro industriel américain
vous êtes très clair dans les chapitres
et ça justifie le matérialisme
extraordinaire voilà mais d'un côté la
loi de l'argent de l'autre loin
totalitaire je reviens je reviens au
roman d'une carrière
tout de même je ne vais pas raconter la
fin du roman
mais c'est tout de même à cette question
vous laisser entendre qu aujourd'hui
d'un bios il n'y a plus la guerre froide
et bien un agent secret hésitera à
sacrifier sa vie hésitera à sacrifier la
vie de la femme qu'il aime
des enfants de cette femme pour une
cause qui une raison d'état qui est
moins pressante qu'avant pour inné de
une idéologie qui n'existe plus oui
exactement ça c'est ça qui va changer
oui c'est ça qui va changer pour nous
tous
les les attitude convenable du passé ne
sont plus valables
les mêmes les attitude héroïque et même
les as tu des héroïques faire ne sont
plus les mêmes les adversaires
maintenant c'est vraiment les hommes en
gris et les autres à leur camion c'était
un pays où un bloc contre l'autre oui
oui pardon nous allons veiller au sein
de zéro n'existe pas sans ennemi il est
dignifier par son ennemi qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette tentative la kgb de
se montrer normale vers dégoûtant digout
effroyable ces gens il
ils doivent cacher la tête en chef dont
toulon dante nous on fait des choses
terribles et de se présenter maintenant
comme comme des pères noël c'est
dégoûtant
c'est dégoûtant je crois qu'il faut
aussi dire qu'il ya des scènes
extraordinaires des feront d'ailleurs
certainement l'objet d'une adaptation
cinématographique passionnante
si cette scène où les houles et où donc
l'éditeur anglais et la jeune katia se
retrouve dans une chambre et savent très
bien qu'ils sont écoutés et donc se
raconte un moment très dramatique où on
a l'impression qu'ils sont sur le banc
la catastrophe en se décrivant c'est une
scène superbe
vous apportez à bleau tout petit
témoignage du du tournage d'ici
donc très vite celui en attendant
quittons de fred kapsiki et un
australien est en train de tourner avec
sean connery michelle pfeiffer est là et
ce film sera montrée oseo en union
soviétique ce n'est pas une coproduction
mais il y a des les il y à une société
qui a acheté les droits
ils veulent sortir le film en même temps
que le roman et c est là kgb a eu
seulement une requête à la au milieu du
tournage ils ont dit vos quito qui ont
beaucoup de nos communications je sais à
peu près tout et c'est là c'est
intéressant parce que dans le dans le
scénario est tiré directement du livre
il ya des échanges qui sont quand même
très dur entre katia se fait 10 katia
elle dit les gens notre notre système se
caractérise par la corruption et
l'inefficacité est le héros anglais qui
jouait pas chaud encore leur ai dit mais
n'ai pas peur de dire ça à voix haute et
elle dit mais non ça ça ça fait partie
de notre nouveau truc nous avons
maintenant la liberté de tout critiquer
mais bien sûr ça ne crée pas des
saucisses nouvelle et tout ça c'est là
c'est trop que penser que les
soviétiques vont voir ça on est passé
enfin je le rappelle c'est aussi un
roman d'amour parce qu'elle ce
personnage superbe de katia c'est que
leurs hommes l'amour dans ce roman
fausse complètement le jeu politique et
ça ça oui mais on voit que ça lui fait
très plaisir cette idée il faut dire je
n'aurais pas ce que vous considérez dans
ce livre là peut-être pour la première
fois que l'amour pour un agent secret
devient quelque chose de plus important
que l'idéologie
oui mais mais j'ai essayé modestement te
dire que ça que peut-être dans l'avenir
l'amour sera valable
nous nous nous sens nous étions enterré
avec cette haine
pendant quarante en plus longs fenêtres
et nous le sommes accoutumés à une sorte
stérilité émotionnel vis-à-vis
d'autres pays et d'autres gens nous
avons plein nous avons préparé la
destruction effroyable de ces gens et
les reversements oui et est maintenant
je voulais dire la responsabilité
individuelle et rentrée est parmi nous
oui mais ce que vous ne
en disant ça vous ne devenez pas un peu
excusez-moi naïf et angélique beaucoup
quel bon tout ça c'est mental mais ça
sera peut-être peut-être ça appartient à
ma pérestroïka personnel mais à ce
moment les sentiments individuels valent
beaucoup je crois que je crois que
l'amour
et le seul la seule situation dans les
romans de john le carré qui échappe
quelquefois à la trahison mensonge à la
la duplicité et ça est ce assez
c'est déjà dans d'autres livres il ya
une autre qualité des romans de john le
carré mais là pas seulement dans celui
ci dans les précédents c'est l'humour
quand même je me dis que la première
qualité pour devenir un agent secret
dans un roman de john le carré c'est pas
la patience est pas le courage c'est
l'humour un nas et c'est difficile quand
même d'avoir autant d'humour que le que
tous vos jeux vous leur en prêter quand
même beaucoup j'ai l'impression oui vous
savez les services secrets sont aussi
des cabarets et utilise attrait d'aider
des gens très amusante
oui c'est pour ça et si on est attrayant
on peut attirer les agents potentiel on
perçoit des jouets à lire des trois
choses par exemple espace à moscou une
semaine auparavant là sont des gens qui
habitent moscou leur balcon s'était
effondré tuant un policier et un chien
et des petits malins de l'immeuble
avaient proposé de faire une collecte
pour le chien c est se situe alors qui
est de vous il vous dit d'un personnage
il avait les larmes d'un vendeur mais
personne ne savait qu'il avait vendu il
ya des phrases formidable la phrase sur
le désarmement
quand il dit si l'américain s'était
donné autant de mal pour le désarmement
que pour envoyer un pauvre type sur la
lune ou coller des rayures roses
dentifrice on l'aurait depuis longtemps
des armements sas que le précisément
est-ce que ça n'est pas une phrase un
peu je dirais un peu angélique aussi
est-ce que provocante provocante
désarmement n'est pas une question
politique c'est une question politique
parce que vous savez la politique
commence avec la volonté ont créé les
ennemis qu'on cherche dans la vie à ce
nous avons créé la sat embauché vic
maintenant il est disparu relie pas
disparu mais il
oui et oui c'est lui qui se crée alors
que l avenir des services secrets on se
convainc s'espionner entre alliés
beaucoup plus qu'avant moi je crains
beaucoup mes ennemis mais je ne crains
pas mes ennemis mais je crains beaucoup
mes amis est ce que c'est à ce sort là
que nous sommes réduits
je vous fais une promesse que si les
politiciens par la vérité s'il abjure
l'agression si il y à la paix partout
dans le monde
moi je n'écrirai plus de romans
d'espionnage
enfin les services secrets vont
continuer y aura toujours des espions et
c'est évident heureusement d'ailleurs on
mettrait sérieusement vous avez dit je
prends un jour il se passe-t-il dans la
vie ou dans une conversation
vous avez dit on on s'attable toujours
d'une manière du rader à des cibles mou
il est dans le il est dans le l'intérêt
des services secrets d'être très dur
avec des gens qui ne savent pas se
défend donc ça va ça va empirer ça
puisque le grand satan n'existe plus que
vont faire les services secrets les gens
déjà dans le livre de peter right on
apprend que les anglais ont espionné ont
posé des écoutes à l'ambassade de france
il ya pas si longtemps et c est ce qu
est ce que ça va empirer ça est ce que
est ce que ce sera les continue ils vont
fabriquer du secret en somme ils vont
fabriquer du secret parce qu'ils ont
besoin de ce que vous savez à ce moment
madame thatcher et ses 2 2
améliorer les les secrets les deux duels
ce thème les services du temps aux noms
des noms à la notion du secret de deux
lycées pressé le vermont taoui de
l'imiter
est-ce qu'on n'a pas dit c'est
l'explication du titre la maison russie
s'agit pas de l'urss on l'avait en
russie c'est une petite maison vous
m'arrêtez une troupe de l'ère
victorienne mais quelque part dans
londres où se trouvent les spécialistes
des services secrets britanniques qui
s'occupe du dossier russie en
particulier de ce dossier si et c'est là
qu'ils suivent par satellite avec des
moyens technologiques très pas croyable
très très peur si tout ce qui se passe à
5 me qui aurait de distance lorsque le
l'éditeur anglais va au contact c'est
éditeur il est où il a toujours un
harnachement pour écouter tous les
autres aussi qu'il enregistre tout je me
demande d'ailleurs qui doit bien arriver
des fois où des agents secrets se trouve
l'un avec l'autre et ils s'enregistrent
l'un l'autre mais sans le savoir
absolument ayez à quand je suis allé
vous voir chez votre éditeur robert
laffont suis demandé si j'allais pas
mettre sur moi quelque chose pour vous
enregistrer
que j'aurais sorti aujourd'hui l'idée me
plaisait à ces deux de vous piéger des
faits et puis finalement j'ai pas su
bricoler enfin je mets ça m'aurait bien
plu
john le carré on arrive au terme de ces
démissions quand même une ou deux de
deux questions générales est ce que le
est-ce que vous recevez des fois la
visite d'agents secrets ou d'anciens
agents secrets qui viennent vous
raconter des histoires pour que vous
puissiez vous en servir non non jamais
je n'ai plus de contact avec de tels
georges et j'ai rencontré par exemple en
israël
des membres du mossad et et de temps en
temps je oui je je visite un ancien
collègue mais mais nous ne discutons
jamais désarmé se clôt mais des gens qui
déjeunent par exemple qui pourrait
spontanément 10 ans john carey a
beaucoup de talent je vais aller lui
raconter ce qui m'est arrivé
ah ah oui mais ça arrive avec chaque
écrivain je crois les les gens sans sens
d'une indiscrétion effroyable ah oui
que j'ai cru comprendre que vous étiez
un homme et vous le disiez à j'aspire à
mettre dans le point qui nous a
interviewé qui est allé vous voir que
vous étiez un homme qui en fait m
être seul oui oui c'est vrai mais la
création c'est quelques chose de
solitaire
il faut avoir des des compagnons mais
mais mais pas trop et pas trop et toit
pour tous tenus carrés dans le journal
de 20 heures d'antenne 2 tout à l'heure
christine ockrent a diffusé un petit
reportage qui était très bien fait très
drôle et malicieux ou interroger des
écrivains sur les effets de la glace 9
de la pérestroïka sur le roman
d'espionnage ont interrogé des
romanciers et je ne sais plus qui a dit
mais peut-être est très sérieusement a
dit mais la chose importante c'est que
si cela continue ce sont les archives
qui vont s'ouvrir
alors est-ce que vous n'allez pas vous
avec quel que soit votre imagination
être débordés par des histoires vraies
qui vont être révélées par l'ouverture
des archives
oui je crois que c'est bien possible
mais mais vous savez le devoir d'un
écrivain c'est de complimenter la
réalité de l'expliquer de d'offrir une
création parfaite alors la vérité
n'existe jamais dans les archives la
vérité entière la vérité humaine pas de
tout sauf que dans les archives ont
trois peut-être enfin la chose
méprisable
bon et ma dernière une chose est ma
dernière question je me carré vous qui
avez été un agent secret et qui est un
romancier
donc vous êtes au fond deux fois le
spécialiste du de la vérité fausses et
du mensonge vrai puis je vous demander
au cours de cette émission combien de
fois vous nous avez menti une fois c'est
pas mal une fois pas grave
oui mais vous me direz pas quant aux
noms ça s'arrête
deuxièmement c'est bien merci pour votre
cravate et surtout et surtout merci
d'avoir tenu cette promesse ce qui nous
a fait grand plaisir
alors bon maintenant donc évidemment il
faut lire la maison russie ça va de soi
si vous voulez trouver ce personnage
retrouver ce personnage s'appelle smiley
qui est vraiment le grand personnage je
ne cadrais vous pouvez dans la
collection bouquins lire la taupe comme
un collégien les gens de smiley d'autre
part alors on vous a montré un certain
moment de les romands pouvaient trouver
comme ça dans leur édition normale comme
la petite fille au tambour ou le miroir
aux espions ou bien un pur espion qui
était l'avant-dernier qui était aussi un
des chefs-d'oeuvre de john le carré
et puis vous pouvez évidemment vous
procurer ces oeuvres en livre de poche
alors lui l'espion qui venait du froid
dans la collection folio et tous les
autres enfin presque tous sont dans la
collection de livres de poche aussi
comme un collégien le miroir aux espions
les gens de smiley je garde celui ci
pour la fin pure espions la petite fille
au tambour un amant naïf et sentimental
à celui ci dans la collection 10/18
c'est une petite ville en allemagne et
puis la taupe celui dans celui ci il
parle de philby mais évidemment c'est un
roman à clé et puis ce qu'on ne sait pas
les françaises passaient qu'avant de
devenir célèbre en publiant l'espion qui
venait du froid vous avez publié deux
romans dans la série noire c'est que
vous disiez tout à l'heure mais faisait
pas des parler de la série noire je me
sens pas alors il y en a un qui
s'appelle chandelle noir c'est le titre
je pose
oui oui chandelle noir bon et il y en a
un autre mais je ne mets pas à parler du
mans contre modène
l'appel du maure adapté au cinéma avec
simone signoret et maxime 1h shell dans
le film est très bien et voilà donc on
peut se procurer
je veux dire je vais pas lui je vais le
lire parce que j'ignorais complètement
l'existence de deux romans dans la série
noire de john le carré dans quelques
nouvelles du 36 15 skoda poste la dictée
de la finale des championnat
d'orthographe vous savez aura lieu
samedi en huit
alors apple vous proposer les annales
complète des championnats des nombreux
tests les dictées des exercices et puis
aussi le jeu du mot juste qui vous
permet de tester vos connaissances avec
quelques grands textes d'écrivains et si
vous répondez bien vous avez de très
nombreux livres à gagner
merci john le carré et 5 ue et bonsoir à
tous et la semaine prochaine
[Musique]